a story of extremes extreme sunshine
today extreme weather 48 hours ago which
inflicted huge damage in this area we've
got a sense of it clearly from Martha
there I'm not terribly far from where
Martha is but I'm I'm actually in a
place called Legacy Harbor Marina and
you are looking at the legacy of
hurricane Ian it's 150 mile an hour
winds it's storm surge of more than 12
feet what happened here and the reason
these boats careered into each other and
are jammed together some on top of
others what happened was at the dock
which flew it was designed to float with
a rising tide it actually floated so
high on the storm surge that it broke
its Moorings that removed the protection
for these yachts and what ensued was
what you see before you something like a
dozen and more Yachts compressed
together and the the sea the water here
is true moon with the trappings of a
Florida Lifestyle by the water it's what
attracts people to a place like this the
sea it's water rivers lakes but I
suppose now they are coming to terms
with the consequences of living
somewhere like this and the kind of
damage inflicted in a place like this by
a hurricane like the lake of which we
saw 48 hours ago it's not just in this
Harbor area that boats have been thrown
around there are streets something like
50 to 100 meters that way where one boat
owner was telling me his boat landed so
you know there is this kind of
Devastation not just across this town
but across this state parts of Florida
that were in direct contact with
hurricane in an all day boat owners have
been coming and going you know these
things cost a million dollars and more
they have been coming and going to
retrieve their possessions one boat
owner was complaining to me of looters
who he said were active last night he
said that some of his daughter's jewelry
had been stolen so that's the kind of
concern that people like Boat Owners
homeowners have at this stage following
an event like this and you know it's not
just this Harbor area it's not just Boat
Owners clearly people have lost our
homes and the infrastructure generally
is straining in these days immediately
after hurricaneian hospitals are without
power and running water this is Lee
County and just up the road one of the
main General hospitals is having to
evacuate its patients out of town to get
treatment so all sorts of problems as
the recovery effort
swings in to action